well folks I can tell you this I've been
doing this show for 20-plus years and I
am 100% convinced that my job is secure
how do I know this because when I start
doing this show I had done so many
stupid things and I still have done so
many stupid things in my life and that
gives people who have done stupid things
permission to call here and you know
we'll all agree that what they did was
stupid but we're going to you know patch
ourselves up dust ourselves off and move
forward you know one stupid thing I've
never done though and this one's running
rampant and it's just really driving me
crazy I've never felt like I was
entitled to something unless I had the
money for it just because I live in the
great land of the US of A that I'm
promised a cellphone I'm promised
certain level of standard of living I'm
promised a car I'm Pro I just don't feel
entitled I've never felt entitled I
guess I grew up in an old-fashioned
household my dad thought work was a verb
it wasn't a management theory some of
you freaking did you want something you
get on the business end of a shovel you
know in the business end of a lawnmower
business into something and make
something happen and so when I see these
little twit reporters with pieces like
this from CNBC I mean this reporter
ought to have his head wrung off and
then the little twits he's reporting on
it's just I laugh and I cry because I
think it's so sad and yet I'm always
going to have a job out of gas most
Americans can't afford new cars for many
Americans new cars are driving out of
reach Jose Hernandez 24 years old lives
in East Los Angeles makes $26,000 a year
working the front desk at a clinic after
a trade-in he financed a new 2013 Civic
e.x for twenty five thousand dollars at
two point three percent for six years
making paying three hundred seventy nine
dollars and monthly payments plus $100 a
month in insurance and he finds that a
new car can be a stretch
I believe most cars are slightly out of
reach out of reasonable price range for
the average American especially
considering most affordable cars don't
last very long and lose a lot of their
value quickly he said so I'm sorry but I
don't mean to be insulting and I but I'm
going to be anyway
the average household income in America
is $52,000 so Jose you're 24 years old
you make half of the national income
average income your income is half of
the national average and you're just
getting started you're a young guy so
what you believe about anything nobody
cares
I believe cars are out of reach of the
average American well you have no idea
what the average American is you're half
of average how's that for insulting me
nobody gives a rip what you think and
you accept this idiot reporter who did
this this who put it in the dadgum
national press what this twenty
four-year-old thinks about cars car
ownership is long sat at the core of
what it means to make it in this country
really according to WHO the definition
of making it in this country is the car
you drive really if you want to get up
and get if you want to get if you want
to get to and around the suburbs you
need to drive no kidding it's an
aspiration that slipped from the grasp
of most as a new report finds that the
average new car is unaffordable for the
average American family in 24 of the 25
largest UITs metro areas consumer gets
to the end of the month and discovers
they have no money left in their
checking account said interest calm
managing editor Mike Santee they spent
every cent they have and they wonder how
on earth they're supposed to save for
their retirement their kids education
it's because he bought a twenty six
twenty six thousand dollar car while
making twenty six thousand dollars this
might be why is no freaking money you
idiots why is did you people get out of
the sixth grade seriously if you're
twenty four years old you make twenty
six thousand dollars a year and you get
a twenty six thousand dollar car you
have
no right to complain that you're broke
cuz you're stupid it's what made you
broke you have no money because you got
all your money tied up in a car a new
car and by the way it's not an American
icon that everyone should in Ford a
brand new car which loses 60% of its
value in the first four years you own it
a twenty eight thousand dollar car
becomes worth eleven thousand dollars in
four years the worst car accidents
happen on the showroom floor it's not an
icon that you're stupid and buy a new
car when you make half of the national
average income you don't need to buy a
new car unbelievable
and the reporter goes on to say that
it's a virtual right for Americans to
own a car because it's necessary for
freedom I can't breathe
this level of this level of entitlement
stupidity
I mean it's necessary for freedom it's
in the Constitution I'm sure our
forefathers put it in there you need a
Honda Civic oh my god I can't breathe
this is ridiculous unbelievable I'll
help you with freedom baby it's called a
bus pass if you're broke you buy what
you can afford until you're not broke
anymore otherwise you ensure that you
stay broke let me try that again
if you're broke you don't go buy a car
with a six year payment god that's dumb
and then wonder why you stayed broke for
six years while putting your entire
annual income the equivalent of it into
a car that's going to lose half of its
value in three years follow the math
here people this is a definition of
mathematical stupidity so no you don't
have a right to a new car and the fact
that new cars are expensive is not a new
thing and it's I'm sure it's the evil 1%
fault that little Jose 24 years old
making $26,000 a year can't afford a new
car
you break it listen I've been in
situations where I couldn't afford to
walk I couldn't afford the energy to do
that I've been there done that
but if you're 26 years old you're 24
years old you make $26,000 here let me
help you with this you buy $3,000 cards
you pay cash for that's only eight of
your car payments Jose by the way then
you got the rest of your life free and
you do something to work on your
marketability so your job when you're 24
it's okay to be working the front desk
of the clinic making $26,000 a year by
the way when you're 34 though son you
need to be doing something else and you
move up but when you work the front desk
at a clinic and you're 24 years old
you don't deserve a new car cuz you're
not the money for a new car
see that's the office of entitlement you
know the money you don't deserve it you
want to deserve it you think you deserve
it then go get the money but you don't
deserve it just because it's an American
right to drive a new car CNBC she shoot
people are morons this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you